Mark I'm pretty convinced that I need to
protect my devices from other folks how
should I think about that how does one
protect their device yeah the first
piece is really taking what the uh the
manufacturers and the companies behind
them are giving you so when you receive
this notice that you know your phone is
ready to get a security update or ready
to get a patch it's really important to
do that ASAP the reason is that once
that alert shows up the attackers
basically know about a vulnerability so
it's kind of like if somebody says you
know on a loudspeaker hey your front
door is unlocked like the longer you
wait the more chance for someone to come
in so I know it can be annoying you're
in the middle of a meeting you're you
know running for a taxi what have you
but the sooner that you do that the
better you are protected on Google
devices you know on Android phones on
our pixel phones we push these out and
try to make it so it's as easy as
possible so there are very few steps
very few things for you to worry about
it will take a few minutes it will use
some Wi-Fi data but that's probably the
first and best recommendation I give
that's a really interesting point
because I think all of us sometimes
whatever device we're using from
whichever manufacturer they always say
oh would you like to update you know and
all this and we're like oh I'm busy I
don't want to restart things etc etc but
to your point it's not just about oh
there's there's been some shady Behavior
that's already occurred and this
protects you but it's a big it's a big
Beacon to say hey in case you didn't
notice Shady folks these are ways that
you you might you might so that's a
that's a really good time to um to to to
update what other things should I I
watch out for one of them is to only
install apps from trusted sources so on
your iPhone it comes from the app store
on your Google Android phone it comes
from the Play Store we test these on a
continuous basis the Google Play
protects scans billions of applications
and is continually updating to ensure
that you're only getting things that
have been vetted and that have gone
through scanning but if you're trying to
get something for nothing or you know
often is the case your kids are trying
to get something for nothing and they
find a free version of a game that's in
some you know dodgy corner of the web
this is kind of like going down a dark
alley and you know buying stuff from
somebody with a trench coat on you get
what you pay for and what that might
include is viruses malware and hacking
threats no no I agree so much with that
because sometimes I've looked for like
even a patch from a well-known photo you
know from some piece of software that
comes and I do it in some of these Shady
actors actually have search results that
are pretty high that they might be a
paid adverse or something like that and
I'm not sure whether they're necessarily
but you realize that the person claiming
to provide a patch for a certain piece
of software isn't necessarily the
publisher of that software so I'm not
saying necessarily that those are good
or bad actors but it is very to your
point be extra careful when you're
installing anything on a any kind of
device who it's coming from we built
something at Google called the security
checkup really designed to be this
One-Stop shop for all your devices
everything you've got connected to your
account so there's a simple link g dot
Co slash security checkup and with that
does is it runs through is your device
protected against local threats you know
somebody grabbing it and just you know
surfing your data is it protected
against online hacking are you up to
date with patches and security issues
are you installing you know apps from
safe locations basically all the tips
that I would give somebody bundled
together into this One-Stop shop g dot
Co slash security checkup